[Music]
in whoopsie-daisy news mr. poopy
butthole mr. poop see some force coming
back it's already you can watch it right
now what are we talking about
good morning season four it's pretty
good it's passable don't spoil it
no I'm not William but I'm saying back
to old Tyler will murder you anyway like
this man my Texas man shot and killed
his wife he spoiled she spoiled
something yeah I said a Texas man shot
and killed his wife he says he was
sleepwalking and I was laughing because
I was like I'll kill you and then I read
that I was like all right we're talking
about this guy so a Houston man who was
charged with the murder of his wife and
he admits to shooting her but he
contends that he wasn't fully
responsible because he was sleepwalking
if he was sleepwalking yeah Raymond
Lazzarini 67 went on trial this week in
the 2013 death of his wife Debra that's
that's our culprit right yeah that's the
type of dude who shoot is good have you
have you heard of life walking [ __ ]
thought he really crazy stuff scariest
whoa you know what that's true my
brother he came into my room at the time
and he peed in our trash bin uh-huh well
they see here in the trash yet no
awareness I was like what are you doing
right now you're saying is that he could
have come in and shot the trash people
do like like full-on yeah they do
actually it's like the I was listening
recently there's one guy he carried his
mattress out in the rain and then laid
on his mattress outside in the rain like
you know he didn't wake up in the rain
or anything do you actually do crazy
dude and that's where I'm like kinda
conflicted about this story because yeah
it's like he but he according to this
story it's it's pretty crazy like he
shot his wife like I think it's like six
times Jesus that's like a sober man the
drunken man's words are so man's
thoughts kind of his wife he's his wife
has been shot six times including in the
head and back like that's pretty crazy
so I'm like this could be either
incredible cover story or it's like
imagine but also imagine like what if
this is true like what if he's actually
sleepwalking and he just [ __ ] kill
his wife you [ __ ] a man should be
punished no you should definitely be
punished because you still [ __ ]
killed your wife so I killed somebody
you guys seen the video of the guy who
[ __ ] sleep walks and then kills
himself
what because because of security there's
security cameras and obviously you look
different no I don't know I think his
eyes were closed or something like that
he was just feeling this way but it's I
think it's in China because it's like
one of those high-rise buildings or just
walked off oh he walked off Vince the
door he and there's like the railing
also you can like jump you like go he
didn't jump he like goes over and just
hangs from the rail and let's go it's
like the scariest [ __ ] that's happening
should you like where everyone starts
walking off the edge of buildings it's
it's insane it's yeah but it was like
yeah he's supposedly like sleepwalking
what are they sure like someone who's
killing themselves I mean they are Jesus
and he just had a demon come into his
home at night if my grandma do their
whole business was right about that [ __ ]
bringing demons into your home that's
what happened probably I do trust me hey
I have no clue what the real scenario is
I didn't look into it it's just scary to
watch and the idea of like potentially
in your subconscious you just like get
up and you get some it was it's like
because of the call of the void or
something like that I read about this
where it's like you get random thoughts
about like well cuz I've had like
thoughts like there's not like serious
thoughts but it's like a random thought
were it's just what if I drank bleach
right now I'm just like a random so is
the thing for it's called all of the
void where it's just like human beings
just have thoughts about like yeah
whatever what would happen if I just
like said this and like [ __ ] died or
whatever and it's weird but it's like a
thing it doesn't mean I'm suicidal yeah
it's like it's too random like that [ __ ]
every time like if I'm really high up on
something and I look straight down
I always think about like where but just
boom you don't do it
but like yeah you're just like what if
you know damn he must hit his wife so
much to sleepwalk and actually commit
that well that's if he's actually sent
we're going subconsciously right like
when you talk about things like so
consciously or it's things that are like
but then you don't you don't necessarily
see what do you think you're seeing
right what you saw an intruder right
well I'm just saying that as a sweep
like like someone who was sleepwalking
right it must have hit him so [ __ ]
hard that he must have [ __ ] hate his
wife so bad that he's like I want to
[ __ ] do it because my dreams yeah my
brother ping that's something he would
do he just didn't get to the toilet in
time so he pay somewhere uh what about
the guy who carried his bed outside in
the rain he didn't always want to sleep
in the rain that's weird maybe it was
too hot need to cool down man look I
know yes yeah he says that are they
they're saying that he is asleep you do
the video but yeah it's a sleepwalker
like he does sleepwalk but and they're
also saying that his son is testifying
saying that he's been going to
psychiatrist for more than a decade and
he's taking prescription drugs that he
sometimes mix with alcohol that's what
you don't [ __ ] do well then that
definitely is Paul if you mix it with
alcohol he said he took the medication
on the day of the shooting so they're
thinking that that might be a
contributing factor again it's really
tragic but at the end of the day if you
shoot somebody you gonna you have to
[ __ ] beat council six times though
like okay as a gun guys I'll wake you up
other gun guy yeah what's the level in
which you feel like you have enough of
like psychological trauma or not even
trauma but like issues where you you
shouldn't have a gun in the household
because for him and you know you
shouldn't grab random [ __ ] or just pick
up random [ __ ] and do whatever like
should you even have a gun in the house
at that point that's that's tricky cuz I
know anything can be Hughes at the
weapon but some things can be used as a
weapon not easy right and this is this
is where I can potentially in a lot of
trouble with industry for me I think
that as a gun owner as a responsible gun
owner I would want to be as safe as
possible with it and that's but I also
want to like say it's a very case by
case things you have a line for yourself
which have a large piece of not other
people you're not putting regulations
we know how people feel about
regulations what is the line for
yourself you're like man I'm
sleepwalking I shouldn't have this me
personally it would depend on the kind
of sleep I like I'm just sleepwalking
like if I just walk around the house or
whatever like that I mean I and I'm
assuming that I have all these things
locked up and like secured in a way that
is you know sensory neurone : you know
it but this guy this he has he had
previous episodes of just sleepwalking
yeah regular sleepwalking has he gone
other than saying he doesn't say and
that's why it makes me feel like maybe
this is just a really like convenient
excuse for him that he was just like I
wanted to do this and this is the thing
that I was gonna do anyway and like I
sleepwalk I'll just put the two and two
together and like come up with a story
or whatever yeah I mean it could be that
that's the thing is that like assuming
that I was just like you know walking
around in it because there's different
degrees of sleepwalking right there's
different degrees of people like walking
around and like some people like go
straight up and like make a whole last
meal or for yourself what's the limit
where you feel like I shouldn't have a
gun myself anymore
I think if I was your digging deep on
that cousin like I don't know I like
even like like people who age right
there's a time where they're like I
shouldn't have a hard animal exactly you
have to be retested when you're a senior
citizen got to be retested for your car
that same idea like when you feel like
you're unfit to drive a car or you're
unfit to have a gun in your own house
like a lot of you can decide yourself
right so whatwhat's your own like your
own life oh yeah if it was getting to
the point where I was getting myself in
danger like the part where I was to be
like I left the stove on or feeling
something I they could've burn the house
down or whatever like that part is
what's this like some I think it once
there's a level of danger where I'm like
not just like che w-what have you went
like in your what you're sleeping
craziness you went and like actually did
things like not so much as dangerous
things but you actually doing things
like picking up things moving furniture
we have to depend on the complexity of
what I was doing then you were like
let's say like [ __ ] you rearranged your
entire living room that's a complex
thing to do right so that would kill
yogurt easily at that point entering the
code get your gun and like shoot
somebody or even yourself right I don't
know we need to see more I guess so we
need to dig more into like because if I
had a condition where I was sleepwalking
I would have to talk to like a
psychiatrist or some sort of like
medical profession would be like how
like how how severe is this like is this
a crazy severe case you know
is something where you know you think is
a professional that I should be way more
cautious with a lot of leaving out and
stuff like that because I mean is it a
matter like [ __ ] I need a baby proof my
house because like I could like easily
just like you know open up [ __ ] you
know drawers and stuff like that if you
like knocking [ __ ] out and stuff it
depends it really depends and me is a
individual I think I'd want that choice
to sort of you know assuming I'm you
know mentally mentally capable of like
you know doing this and I'm not like no
nothing you're a crazy person you're
just sleepwalking around no I don't know
but this guy sounds like you might be
crazy so that's true shooting on my ID
channel hat for this guy
what is it was their ID channel like no
investigative it's a channel all about
like discussion TV yeah so like putting
on my police hat right now I would be
like okay does this guy have a motive
did he did he have a reason for killing
no there's no thing it says that yeah
he's mean the the son weighed in and
said that he was on medication would
have assuming the son also cares about
his mother right it would have been like
oh yeah my dad gets into fights all the
time with my mom yeah they just sound
happy all the time yeah then there's no
information about that kind of stuff I
mean the case might still be on doing
considering how like hot yeah of a
headline this is they would have
mentioned oh yeah they fought all the
time so let's say we're having them
let's say we believe would say he was
sleepwalking what do you guys think
would be an appropriate thing or it
doesn't matter like it's what do you say
it's like because of how harsh it was
would he'd go to like 20 years
dudes pretty old like this dude's pretty
old already I think that like any kind
of like jail sentence at this point is
is the brothers like Knights yeah that
point if he's super old if we're gonna
take away his gun he's not super old
meets like 67 like yeah well I mean I
should take away his gun I don't know if
they would put him in jail forever or
anything like that maybe like a like a
short manager I feel like it could be
four even if it's like four years like
this dude doesn't he's an investor she
if the jury fully decided that it was
completely like sleep 100 yeah it's
completely accident think it would be a
harsh sentence that still is
manslaughter like uh like you maybe you
run someone over and you kill them but
that's like your your innocence well you
did all of like yeah the things that
you're supposed to do with it was also
to know he was mixing napkin also you
can also argue that because he's taking
alcohol with this or description
medication yeah he's at fault yeah for
sure with that but then like what I
guess article didn't say if he drank
alcohol at that time right I did it and
and based on how recent this article is
its published November 6 the trial is
probably still ongoing so that's
probably why they publish things about
that's why they can't come things they
can publish what it's about I think but
if it's ongoing can't talk about the
jury can see it and then it's like this
what the case is still like they're
still deliberating about it in court so
what do you guys think should happen to
him if like it's it's true yeah his
everything he said is completely true
like he loved his wife to pieces and
then to pieces if it's true like my
worry is the fact that he missed alcohol
and drugs but we don't know if he did
that night though yeah but but I think
wasn't it stated that drunken stupor and
like he's also doing it or is it like
one of the people who who that night he
took the prescription at like 6 p.m. and
then at 10 p.m. he's like Jiri rooms are
like by this is why I don't believe it
how loud is a gunshot cuz you said six
shots right she shot her six times
shotgun shotgun no I think it's like a
handgun okay yeah no but she'll are six
times how loud does it need to be to
like wake your ass so I hear sometimes
they don't get me wrong he's obviously a
gun user so he goes the gun range and
he's like conscious or like many losses
hearing hope does never he doesn't use
your protection you can't hear [ __ ] uh
no but I mean like I feel like you would
wake up after like firing a weapon thing
but like they talked about the guy that
ran out in the rain with a [ __ ]
mattress I also talked about the guy who
let you kill like [ __ ] that jumped
off a building I'm just saying like I
don't
reason his hair holding on to the bar I
think normal senses count they know you
sleepwalking that's with you out do
right what's that like when you fall
asleep you like your senses getting numb
down yeah that's when you bring in the
expert that's what you get on the jury
you have an expert come in they explain
like this is what sleep deprivation does
not believe the expert like I love it
being our jury is actually pretty like I
have no experience in sleepwalking
whatsoever no one has ever caught me
sleepwalking so I really say [ __ ] the
sky though for the people that do the
fans that are watching let us know what
your spawn experiences are and like what
it's completely like because we are
curious and we just really kind of want
to understand them I still think that
this guy's hella guilty for just killing
his wife in the [ __ ] head sixth time
I think he's guilty regardless cuz he
did the act and I think that regardless
of whether or not you want to talk about
intention and yeah how much do you guys
care about judicial systems being about
Reformation is a Reformation it's like
yeah yeah you're talking about like yeah
when you reform yeah right to help
people get to get better or like someone
who did something terrible to to like
it's like what system or do you care
more about just punishing people because
understand our Reformation yeah cuz I
feel like just punishing people what's
the benefit of anybody this is now
you're going into like see if people
care about other subjects
[Music]